joining me now to discuss this is dr
cornel west himself
acclaimed author activist and professor
who's now rejoining the union
theological seminary in new york
as the dietrich bonhoeffer chair uh dr
west thank you so much for coming back
on the show
you announced back in march that you
were ending your efforts to get tenured
at harvard
and that you'd be leaving to join new
york's union theological seminary
so why did you share this pretty uh
outspoken letter now
well i i was told that i had to write a
letter resignation
by june 30th and that's what i attempted
to do and then i said you know
as my dear brother prince would say as a
sign of the times
i didn't want to go into the night
silently i think it's very important we
try to bear
witness to certain kinds of quests for
truth and goodness and beauty and for me
as a christian the holy
and i do think we live in a time of such
overwhelming spiritual
decay and moral decrepitude
where moral causes are being reduced to
just market brands
where any quest for spiritual excellence
and greatness
is being reduced to financial success
and we've got too many precious students
of
all colors coming through who need to be
exposed to
rich socratic legacies of athens and
prophetic legacies of jerusalem and
the rich traditions in africa martin
rich legacies of uh exemplary figures in
asia indigenous peoples
the quest for truth and goodness and
beauty and the holy
is something that every culture every
civilization
produces and the question is how do we
keep alive those high standards of
excellence my brother
in your letter you say that it was your
pro-palestinian
activism your pro-palestinian politics
was the reason why you were refused
tenure at one point you call it the
cowardly deference
to the anti-palestinian prejudices of
the harvard administration
is that the only reason you think they
denied you tenure and a lot of your
critics are saying
well where's your evidence to show it
was support for palestinians it cost you
your tenure
it's a big claim what's the evidence for
it
well one is there's been a number of
candidates to come through who've been
denied tenure on to their deep
solidarity with the palestinian cause
alongside
their sophisticated scholarship one
includes in fact
a highly acclaimed jewish israeli sister
so it's not just a matter
of either black or white or or
palestinian or arab
is those who are concerned about truth
and condition of truth is to allow
suffering to speak and certainly the
suffering
among our precious palestinian brothers
and sisters are is just beyond
measure in terms of what is happening
under the israeli occupation
but in in beyond that though the issue
of how to come to terms with
israeli-palestinian
uh uh uh uh uh realities
uh it's difficult to have a respectful
conversation
anybody critical for the most part of
israeli occupations viewed as anti-jews
and anti-semitic
you get demonized overnight and so it's
very
clear that those who are willing to step
out
are going to be targeted in a variety of
different ways i'm not the only one i
mean mark lamont it was a whole
wave of folk who experienced this but
keep in mind this my brother
yes that i as an isolated person here at
home but you know still very privileged
and very
very very uh blessed that this kind of
devaluing and dismissing and
disrespecting of black people
people of color and those who are
willing to step
out and be critical of taboo issues in
this case the palestinian cause
that that's happening across the board
it's just not harvard this is community
colleges state colleges
universities including black colleges a
lot of people talk to west black
colleges and so forth so well
the black colleges are wonderful but
they've got their children
i'm not disputing of course that it's
very difficult about this subject and
that bad faith actors
the bad faith actors uh misuse uh the
anti-semitism charge in the context of
criticizing israel
but in terms of your own experience your
critics would say can you name someone
at harvard
who brought up the palestine issue with
you because your critics
like michael cohen who's a boston globe
columnist former state department of
speech
he did accuse you of anti-semitism he
says you shouldn't have said talking
about the israeli occupation of
palestine
is a taboo issue among certain circles
in high places which is what you said in
february he said you're feeding into an
anti-semitic trope by saying that
can you respond to him and can you offer
evidence of someone actually saying to
you you know what
cornell west you've got no future here
because of your pro-palestinian politics
well one anybody who wants to do serious
research
can go into the heart of the harvard
archive and come up with the rejection
of three high quality professors
all three of whom were deeply critical
of the israeli occupation
but would be in fact acceptable based on
academic
criteria in my case it couldn't be
academic criteria i was university
professor princeton
as well as harvard it could be a matter
of age but if that were the case then
ageism was operating and so i don't
think it's that
so it has to be political what other
candidates would it be in my case
my dear solidarity with bernie sanders
who i supported twice i don't think that
would be a strong enough issue that
would lead for them to be
so fearful of just allowing me to go
through a ten year process
after receiving tenure at yale in 1984
in university professors twice at
96 in 2002 what other reason
do i have it would be nice if the
harvard administration
harvest president were to lay out what
the argument is let's hear what it is
it's interesting that it's interesting
that harvard have not offered any real
substantive response to your accusations
so
we'll wait and see we'll we'll see what
happens there but stepping back for a
second there's someone in academia
can you put into context what's going on
on american campuses right now because
on the one hand
you hear from the right that school beds
are hotbeds schools are hotbeds for
liberal indoctrination
lefties are snowflakes liberals want to
cancel everything
and then you see people like nicole
hannah jones being denied tenure you see
the banning of critical race theory
uh you see what's going on with yourself
describe to us what's happening in
american universities right now
from your perspective but it's the
treatment of my discussion nicole hannah
jones is just
despicable and i'm glad to see she and
brother coats making their way to uh
to howard howard's a great great
institution and it's going to have its
own challenges in terms of
internal struggles unionization of his
adjunct professors the envy and
resentment that is true in any
professional context including including
universities but the problem is this my
brother
that there's a market
driven quality that every institution in
america so the united
the universities are have become so
commodified
they are bureaucratized and top heavy
so they're concerned about money
relation of donors and benefactors on
the one hand
and at the same time they've got
bureaucrats at the top that are obsessed
with diversity
but the shadow of jim crow the legacy of
white supremacy still cuts
very deep but in a very very subtle
manner
but a lot about diversity and equity and
inclusion and so forth and so on but
when you actually look at the structures
and the institutions of the place
even when it's more colorful at the top
with blacks and whites and asians and so
forth
translated on the ground and translated
on the ground means not just the impact
on students
but on the percentage of
different groups represented across the
board not all of them in afro-american
studies
all of them in a certain studies but
across the board you still see
shadows of jim crow so you get this
mixture and it's really
in some ways a lethal mixture of
commodification
market drivenness obsession with money
status
rankings and on the other hand the
inability of diversity to come to terms
of what is most
important which is the quest for truth
goodness beauty and some sense of the
whole if you're religious like myself
that's what university should be about
the counterweight against
free hatred hypocrisy
fear the freeing up of all of us to
engage in serious quests
so dr west let me let me jump in before
we run out of time in terms of the quest
for truth
we're seeing a battle against the big
lie in america we're seeing a battle
against voting rights from the
republicans
earlier today more than 150 companies
from pepsico to amazon to target
issued a letter voicing their support
for voting rights
um you have joe biden giving his big
speech yesterday
talking about democracy versus autocracy
have a listen
must ask those who represent us at the
federal state
local levels will you deny the will of
the people will you ignore their
voices we have to ask are you on the
side of truth or lies
fact or fiction justice or injustice
democracy or autocracy
that's what it's coming down to
do you agree dr west that is democracy
versus autocracy and if so
is joe biden up to the fight
well i hope he is if not we've got to be
as a group of citizens willing to engage
in collective action to preserve the
best of democratic projects
but no the united states is very
oligarchic at that point
it's hard to call us in any way a
substantive democracy the biden himself
has been so tied to corporate elites so
tied to wall street
so tied to the oligarchs in america now
when he what he calls
autocracy i would call authoritarian i
would call
escalating fascisms and nail fascism
both around the world as well as inside
the united states with trump and company
so that i think uh there's just
democratic aspects of oligarchic america
but we're in a much
much dimmer moment than than what he's
projecting and notice he just said mama
what about the filibuster